you do audition with a new map TV I
didn't why no I didn't get the call but
John Barinholtz didn't now he's a writer
I know I saw him over there yeah yeah
what you don't want this something you
don't want to do no I never said that
no yeah look into me right now SNL guy
you want to do SNL I came close to close
how close they flew me to New York six
times six times six times at one point
Lorne Michaels told me he was gonna hire
me and I just had to had to wait for
Jason Sudeikis to leave and then another
year went by I auditioned again I
auditioned on that stage three times
oh and I met with Lauren three times Wow
oh my god and then and then when you
didn't get it how do you feel anger I
felt anger was that mad resentment
sadness yeah it was three years man
three years I went through this oh my
god we need to go through it again never
you will not go out again I think so
you want me to get in yeah really want
to I don't really want to hear it I
think me not getting that show and I'm
not a religious man I don't believe in
God but I think it was a blessing in
disguise me not getting that show
because at Second City I was drinking
and I was drugging yeah
and everything else not meth not heroin
yeah everything else and I think the
stress of that show would've just MIT I
would have just done more that to deal
with it what I think I would I killed
myself
I think one died you 100% yeah yeah I
mean that is great that you know that
you can't do that he relapsed on when he
got mad you did yeah
I we had 12 years of sobriety but
leading up yes I got sober when I was 17
whoa no that's what I spent my all Wow
and I got man up for you and I show up
and three months in I'm [ __ ] 100%
24/7 relapse like that you know what it
probably would have been a similar
picture for you New York yes I know
stress of that [ __ ] show
oh my sketch got cut oh I'm you know oh
yeah in the light nightlife yeah yeah
yeah it would have been bad but I think
you would be great on a show like that
but you would never do
I didn't say that I love it's me you're
above it
no there's a lot of guys my friend Fahim
Anwar he opened for me mm-hmm
he got an audition and he didn't do it
because I just don't think it's what I
want to do he wants to do sketch but
he's like it's just not at the level of
what I wanted to do right and also if
you're not you know if you're not in
need of that immediate paycheck you can
make choices like that so if you I think
that that isn't necessarily a bad move
on for him you know he's doing well he
just got signed with CA nobody needs
money he doesn't know training the
training videos all else fails go back I
will say this love biggest break of my
career good yeah yeah of course yeah you
look it so when you got you auditioned
obviously or no I auditioned for three
different parts and then oh it wasn't
right for any of them and so then they
wrote apart for me that's why characters
thank you that's why my character's name
is Chris on the show interesting so you
went in for Alison right Rosen thank god
Alison Jones saw me in Chicago at Second
City she saw me on stage so that was
great because she saw what I could do
and how cool of her to [ __ ] fly to
Chicago to just check out Talent yeah I
want to say this I don't have ever said
this on the show about Alison I'm going
to tell you this right now Alison Jones
is a casting director in LA and
[Music]